all right so we have a great group here
it's really interesting selection of
films and all what I'd like to do first
is just kind of go down the line here
and I was wondering to each each of you
could talk a little bit about the origin
of your projects with where the project
originally came from you know how you
originally came in for the concept
Academy better beyond it occurred to us
that animals have similar issues as
people as humans but they don't get
judged for it you know they're just
allowed to be the way they are and so I
you know you get a little bit jealous I
suppose but we wondered you know what if
they were you know they if they're in
today's society as sophisticated animals
and they had to adapt and we thought a
group therapy session was the best place
to show that we also wanted to deal with
the question of whether people or
animals should change their behavior to
fit in better or whether people should
or others should accept them for who
they are so that was the kind of dynamic
that we were playing with there and we
wanted to make fun of group therapy so
for for about it was loosely inspired by
my own life growing up I feel like ever
since I was little my mom has treated me
like her precious little dumpling I'm an
only child
so she she was very overprotective of me
very much like a part of my life even
now and I and I just wanted to explore
that relationship between an
overprotective parent and this chanda
and a kid and I've always loved really
dark fairy tales as well like little
gingerbread man and I kind of wanted to
do it Chinese bow version of that and
then that twist ending was definitely
inspired by again my mom like she would
still
even now hold me close and be like Oh
Doh me I wish I could put you back in my
stomach so I knew exactly where you were
at all times like Oh mom that's sweet
but that's the inspiration behind bow
and I I'm just I'm the lucky producer
that got to help tell Domi's story and
put the crew together and you made a bow
they made a bow during the making of a
bow so it's really great I want to put
back in my stomach so yeah and basically
the idea for me came and initially from
sort of a desire to UM to explore a sort
of a woman's in her life on screen I
mean it's sort of an abstract idea and
just explore it on screen and then also
especially when I started really getting
into the film and I'm getting into the
script even and I think the my own
grandmother's were kind of inspiration
for the main character in terms of by
trying to remember what their lives were
like before you know before they were
just my grandmother's before that you
know I only knew them as in that from
that point of view so I really wanted to
kind of think about what their lives
were like before that and see them more
as whole people rather than just this
one aspect of their lives so that's kind
of where I came from for me and they
produce her late afternoon so and Louise
talked to me about the film were really
really liked well I liked Lewis's work
before then but I loved the sensitivity
of the film and how touching
it's such a sad illness dementia there
was this positive but not unrealistic
feeling about it so we will be looking
at also happy memories and seeing how
people are living with the illness and
not necessarily always sad or confused
they also are happy sometimes and and
even if it's really hard for the family
when they leave these were confusing
moments is really comforting for them
that they're supportive and again you
know like we wanted to treat her with a
lot of respect but it's very precious
for the family when these moments at the
end of the film happened when they
connect and they know they're very
precious because they only last for you
know maybe a few moments so we wanted to
embrace that
Bobby and I were both lucky at a young
age to know what we wanted to do with
our lives we both wanted to be animators
and we were also both lucky enough to
have family members who supported us in
my case I had a grandfather who
recognized to me at a young age five
years old that I would probably grow up
to be a Disney animator and I did but he
passed away when I was 10 and when I got
into Disney at 27 my mom told me the
story of what he said to her and that
resonated with me and that feeling of
knowing what I wanted to do and then
seeing it through and then finding out
who is there to support me and how much
that meant to me at a young age we
wanted to put that into the film yeah
all of us kind of felt that way into the
story at Tyco of just kind of like
chasing after a dream and wow that is
like something that we all went through
and it was and we worked hard to get
there but we also wanted to shine a
light on everyone that supported us
along the way so for me it was my mother
and it's not it's not a like a common
thing but she encouraged me to get into
art school she signed me up for art
school and she was my biggest
cheerleader into that and I don't take
that for granted so for us for one small
step was just kind of chasing after that
big dream and shining a light and those
supporting you along the way so yeah for
me my film actually started as a drawing
I did back in 2007's over ten years ago
trying to get a job at animation studios
and it was the kid walking from his
mom's home to his dad's car and I you
know share our work with friends and
this generated the most kind of response
to conversation people would share
stories about their divorced parents and
kind of realized how common that is in
society and also realize it's not really
talked about an animated film much so I
really wanted to capture the childhood
perspective of divorce in animation
and yeah just deal with like kind of
surreal imagery and that was kind of the
basis for weekends all of you here have
had a certain amount of experience
beyond the making of your one short film
a number of you have had experience in
long film working in long projects as
well as short projects i I just want to
talk about the concept of shorts for a
little while like what do you personally
enjoy about the short film format and
what brings you back to the short film
format and let's start with Trev and go
this way I'll put you on the spot I know
I'm sorry
I for one I mean as an individual you
can kind of find your own voice and
perspective and it's not the size of a
feature which takes hundreds of people
to make so it's actually manageable in
some ways and I think I love shorts
personally because you get these like
really potent perspectives that are all
done uniquely so I just think they're
really fascinating and amazing and
overlooked honestly yeah I build off
that like the intimacy I'm just kind of
like like putting your own voice out
there your personal voice out there and
just kind of like saying hey does anyone
else feel this way you know and then you
hopefully you can pair with somebodies I
feel that way too and then we can make a
film together we can make art together
but I think that's what we did you know
and one small step right we all find we
all found our way into this story I
think I think with short specifically
you can try things that people might be
more skeptical of when there's a hundred
and eighty million dollars on the line
but yeah I mean the thoughts I would
echo the thoughts shared by these two
and you can be very iconic and efficient
with your choices and make a bold
decision to not have any dialogue which
I think three of the five films no
dialogue that's a lot of fun to play
with and you get to really embrace the
strengths of imagery and brevity freedom
freedom of
expression of doing something a little
bit more risky and no you know sometimes
when you when most the time when you're
gonna work on a feature there's a lot of
voices and there's a lot of things that
you need to you know get more
constraints and you have a lot more
freedom on it on a short and you can
experiment a bit more yeah I'm gonna M
also say that some ideas are just they
are shorts you know they're that's the
best format for those ideas and it's
nice to be able to just commit to that
as an idea and then also I'm gonna say
that I'm as much freedom as you get with
shorts us look at serious limitations
limitations the time money energy of
people and passion and and I think in a
way those limitations can make a project
almost better because you have to be
very clever about what choices you make
you really have to commit to what the
films about and it makes you sort of
kind of really focus in on what the
short is you don't have much time to get
it across so yeah that's why I like
shorts a lot yeah so yeah it's a lot of
risk-taking and creatively which I'm
sure domi will talk about more but I
feel like as a producer what was
exciting about working on this short
producing this short is risk-taking with
with our crew so it was the first time a
lot of us held these particular
leadership roles and I'm really happy
for to share that many women were in
leadership roles and on our short so not
only is it our first time but we're
Domi's the first female shorts director
at Pixar it's the first time I produce
yeah and yeah we had our production
designer it was the first time she had
done that job and our our production
manager our Hearst yeah a lot of first
our technical supervising technical
director is typically a DP and he wanted
to try try the technology side some more
and yeah so being able to have this be
able to take risk should try on these
like big people's shoes on this on this
shorter format was super exciting and
encouraging for me and us yeah yeah I
echo what everyone says it's just it's
just so awesome to be able to experiment
with do
types of stories different types of
styles and shorts but for me I just
loved the like working with a small crew
like it felt like we were on a pirate
ship even though I worked at Pixar and
and it's such a huge studio like working
on a short you still get to be scrappy
and you have to be like creative and
inventive and there's not going to be a
ton of resources available to you and
that's what I love about it like you
kind of have to push yourself to think
outside the box and wear different hats
and like do like take on different roles
like that was my favorite part about
directing a short so for me I I grew up
in Canada thinking that short films was
what I always wanted to do I was
influenced by the work of the National
Film Board of Canada you know so proud
to be able to make films with the NFB
now and so Alison and I hadn't actually
made it short for like 25 years so
coming back to that now is is a really
gratifying thing and to have the film
here amongst these is such an honor I
would agree with all these great points
except just to add I think what we enjoy
in a short film as opposed to long form
is we can do most of the creative work
ourselves and so you really hone it to
exactly what you want to do which
sometimes you have to it's nice working
with other people and collaborating but
it is also nice to make it very personal
that's true I gotta ask a quick question
for all the Canadians here and that is
that in in two films or three films I
saw this is at CN Tower yes okay so to
make sure there's there not another
Tower in Vancouver I don't know okay I
haven't been there in a while so I don't
now I regret not putting this
so an interesting point when you think
about you know all of you your films are
very personal and in films films have a
very individual style but you're all
working with crews too like all of you
like have about you know dozen more
people working on your team how do you
like how do you like working as a
basically as supervisors running a team
you like what is the challenge is up
when I was a director I remember
animator and one of my mentors was at
all Disney animator named Seamus Culhane
and Shane was told me he says he says
directing has nothing to do with your
ability to draw your ability to motivate
people with your personality so so what
did you find as a as a as a challenge
whatever directing other people we had a
crew but mostly for like paint and trace
and we had a couple of people do a small
part of our animation so the majority of
it was by ourselves so we were just
trying to match everything to what we
were doing so it wasn't too difficult in
this case we had a privilege with the
way that we work with with the NFB is is
it's very creator driven and we don't
get notes from anybody no one says when
you make some changes like this that
they want to support our vision and one
of the reasons why we want to make a
short film after doing TV series was
because we wanted to have the pen in our
hand and be actually acting the
characters and making them do exactly
what we wanted to do and so that was
very gratifying and last time we did it
was cell painting cells which was just
horrific so now digital was a revelation
but it didn't take it still took longer
actually
I don't get that yeah for me the biggest
challenge in making this short was just
stepping up into this leadership
position is uh not being able to rely on
my I guess superpower which is drawing
so I am a storyboard artist originally
and uh and I feel like ever since I was
little that's how I was able to
communicate with people was through
drawings but as a director you're kind
of tasked with being able to communicate
in a very succinct you know like way to
like a large group of people with words
and not so much with drawings and that
was for me like the most challenging
thing but it was I I learned so much
from the role I learned to just rely and
trust my team and the leadership and
also just to like open up and bring the
crew into the world of bow we went on
several field trips to you know San
Francisco and Oakland Chinatown we did
lots of research at Chinese restaurants
like several hundreds of doublings
dumplings were harmed in the making of
many yeah that was really awesome just
being able to share the singular vision
with like a whole crew of people was
very challenging but really gratifying I
just want to jump in with but I remember
one like being in story sessions where
where you know people are throwing
around ideas and is always one person
going you know I think we should do as
human sacrifice here no I didn't see
that at all and only a few weeks later
pitching another section you know we
really should try a human sacrifice no
no
so sometimes it's like you want to take
everybody's input but you still want it
to be your film you don't keep it in so
yeah keep going so oh yeah I well I it
started at Pixar actually as a PA
production assistant on a short film it
was one band band and so I think for me
I've done many different positions that
Pixar from from PA to artist to
production coordinator and manager and I
think what I try to do is put myself in
everyone's shoes when I'm asking
something of them and
try to lead with as much compassion as I
can and yeah and like Tomi said we
really just tried to people brought them
brought so much heart and love to this
they loved being a part of this crew and
so we wanted to encourage them to put
their ideas out there too there are a
lot of little things that didn't come
from us came from you know somebody's
idea to there's a little mother and
turtle mother and baby turtle sculpture
that's in the mother's bedroom that one
of our artists he had a sculpture like
that from his mom and so he wanted to
draw something like that and put it in
and there's a lot of things like that
down to like the costume design and so
much care and thought and we just wanted
to provide a space for people to be able
to bring that to it and work through
their mom issues and I think for me a
lot of the joy of working with it with
the team on the on the film was actually
and being able to work with people and
know that they were going to bring
something that I hadn't yea thought of
to the to the project or they were going
to bring more to something that I wanted
to you know so me as a director I'm not
telling them specifically I want this
color and this thing and this thing I'm
saying this is what I want I did this
scene this is the emotional point of
this scene this is where I wanted to go
like what do you think you would do and
so it was like being able to actually
bring that out of people was really
enjoyable and then also being able to
cast people so like being able to cast
my animators for their scenes knowing
where their strengths were and seeing
that and then like you know rewarding
them with the scenes they knew they
really wanted to do and like that was
really and it was really great to see
the artists grow in the production and
then you know develop as artists and
then kind of like bring it all together
and within the film as well so that was
really enjoyable producer just stuffed
them with cakes and sugar as a basic
food group
yeah we we brought fruits once and they
didn't work as well for me I think the
biggest challenge many times said as a
user you are you're an audience first
audience you are a professional beggar
so you hold the time asking for things
especially in shorts but you don't have
enough resources you learned really well
to you know move your eyelashes and
blink a very and really back yes totally
and and also I think the one of the
biggest challenge was that sometimes I
have the louise is a great director of
it and for good and bad she has a big
production mind - so she worries which
is lovely you know she worries about the
oh do we have enough money oh this is
gonna be very expensive oh that doesn't
know enough time for this and I just
have to say relax just don't worry about
it
I like don't worry about it and then I
go behind the court doesn't let go sugar
but the thing is like I you know I'm
there and I want as well to make the
best film and I'm actually the worst bad
because when they said no that's gonna
be too expensive I know that's great
it's tried to make and I think you've
already put it yeah it was and and also
you're a big cheerleader as well as as a
producer and I think you have to always
know well the vision of the director is
and where everybody is putting on the
table and kind of really always trying
to get to where you wanted to go from
the beginning and and when you go to the
side too much helping everyone to keep
going - no losing their minds in the
process we had a lot of practical
challenges because we're a startup
company and our producer Xiao foo Zang
there was a Disney animator with bobbi
and myself for several years and he
founded our company with a footprint in
Wuhan China as well as Burbank so most
of our crew speaks Mandarin Bobby and I
are both American and only speak English
and our producer shel foo who's a great
director in his own right speaks both
and he would travel back and forth and
set up a space for both sides of the
crew and Bobby and I went in very humble
just trying to be receptive to all the
things that we didn't know and creating
a compassionate
space and trying to earn the trust of
people who don't speak the same language
as we do but have to believe that we're
guiding the story in the film in a right
direction and creating a story that they
can all relate to so that it feels
connected to all of us yeah I think for
the most part like Andrew and I when we
became directors it was not about the
work that recreated us ourselves it was
about mentoring everyone else on our
crew and for me that was the biggest
thing was like seeing them grow and just
seeing them create great work and it
wasn't about the work that we created
anymore it was just about the work that
they created like every day of seeing
the Wuhan China crew and and we were so
proud of them every time they you know
we gave note and they rose above all our
expectations so I think like the biggest
thing for me that I discovered what as a
director is is you sort of lose that ego
and it's not about the work that you
create it's about the work that your
team creates and you want to Shepherd
that and you want to mentor them and you
want to you want them to create their
best work and I think that was a
humbling experience for me so yeah for
me it was extremely personal project
that has a lot of elements from my own
childhood in it and I had worked on it
for a really long time and I always
thought I was gonna do it by myself but
that was pretty foolish I was lucky
enough to meet the production designer
around it was named Chris Sasaki and he
was the first person to collaborate with
me and helped me the smart work and I
just really evolved and grew and kind of
opened me up to work with more people
and I never would have been able to
finish this by myself so I think just
learning to trust people sharing
sentiment a lot of people are are saying
but yeah I think people are really great
and I think the experience working on
this is really beautiful and reaffirming
through me I want to thank you all for
coming here let's have a great hand
cross filming
you